heads up guys my name is a cello and
welcome to the April 2015 update video
so I've decided that I'm going to
basically do an update video once every
month just to keep everyone in the loop
as to what's happening because this
channel is generally all over the place
so first up in case you have been living
under a rock we've basically been
working on the Sparky engine for the
past few weeks okay so the goal of the
Sparky engine for those of you who don't
know is basically just to make a engine
in C++ a game engine that we can use in
lot and air and that's kind of the
primary purpose okay so that I don't
have to write everything from scratch
and let them there I can kind of just
build upon this existing engine now that
being said light and air is coming up
extremely quickly let's just say that
right so we've only got about mmm like
15 days basically a while I'm recording
this right we've got 15 days left until
of them there which which is above two
weeks but it is not much time so I'm
going to kind of accelerate the
development of this barky engine now
that being said luckily it is Easter
weekend right now which means that I've
got a few I've basically just got a few
days of work which means I can stream
more but the question that I'm going to
ask you people because the series is
kind of supposed to involve you is um
are you okay with more or less kind of
live videos because what I've been doing
lately is I honestly I'm a bit sketchy
about the idea of basically producing
videos completely live because usually
there's a lot of debugging usually I
don't know what I'm doing right that's
usually how this goes down because I
need to plan everything I need to test
it maybe it won't work you know all that
stuff now if I I'm the other part of me
is like maybe it would be cool to have a
series at least one series on my channel
in which stuff is basically all over the
place because that gives you an
opportunity to see everything that goes
in goes into the development of
something like this not just the
polished kind of I don't know produced
video right so if you're okay with the
video is being basically three to four
times longer but it's more of like I
guess it shows more of the process then
that's great post a comment below and
hopefully I'll be able to do it that way
one important thing I did want to
mention
was the fact the code is on github right
if I do make this series like this or if
I kind of stopped doing my outside
planning and start doing everything live
and all this experimentation and testing
and debugging and all that stuff live
since the videos are going to be so long
they're going to be harder to follow
along and copy the code down but the
code is on github so I'm thinking maybe
that's not an issue maybe it's a series
that you just want to watch you know
while you're lying in bed and not really
follow along with but just watch to
learn and I guess just to have fun it
should be quite entertaining so that's
kind of my situation with the Sparky
engine series so hopefully you guys will
post your opinions in the comments below
and we'll get some kind of discussion
going now speaking of discussions I've
launched an IRC server okay so Internet
Relay Chat i think is what i see i
probably should have definitely prepared
for this and actually googled what IRC
stood for because i forgot but let's
quickly to that now long yes Internet
Relay Chat okay so I didn't know that
but I was just making sure anyway IRC is
basically like an instant messaging kind
of thing but it involves all of you okay
anyone can join you just have to type it
in nickname and your written so if you
go to il co-chair accom you'll be able
to there's like a little web client you
can just punch in a nickname and join
not currently you can also buy it by the
way you can obviously use your own IRC
client you can download something like
hex chat for example and it's free and
everything and then you can that that's
like a desktop client that you can just
use to join into this server and you'll
be able to chat with everyone else but
it'll be on your desktop instead of on a
web page you might want to do that
instead right but the point is if you do
want to do that that's instructions or
there should be on aisle seat of the
chair calm how to join using your own
client but basically it's just port 6 8
8 8 and the the the channel is called
hash main okay so its main and that's
basically information you need so I
encourage a lot of you guys to to hop on
there I'll try and be there as as as
much as possible and hopefully it'll
just be kind of like every time I stream
there's this really nice and high
quality twitch kind of chat where you
guys are all talking about all different
things not necessarily just what you're
seeing on screen when I'm streaming but
you
talking what you're talking about all
these different like I don't know areas
of game development how to do white and
what you've been working on and it's a
really nice community discussion so
unfortunately when the stream ends that
kind of discussion dies so this is my
attempt to kind of prolong that thing
and enable you guys to do it whenever
you want not just when I'm streaming so
I'll see dr. chanoor calm will let you
do that I've also made a new site which
is live dr. channel calm its work in
progress i'm still kind of working out
the layout to make it kind of nice I
guess but if you go to live the trainer
calm that's going to be my new kind of
site that I promote it as my like
instead of two ish on TV it'll be this
because it embeds twitch to it embeds
the twitch livestream the twitch chat
and the IRC chat so that you can kind of
see both all in one screen instead of
having it on like to model something I
think it's a really nice layout I'm
still kind of polishing it but hopefully
you guys will like that and I'll just
let you guys use the IRC chat at orbit
or the twitch chat or both whilst
watching a live stream cool so that's
the idea that's a few things that I've
done the other really big thing I wanted
to point out was the fact that I have
completely revamped the forums so if you
guys aren't aware it's the channel com
full / forum so we can just go to the
turn out of coma click on forums it's
now kind of full screen it's kind of a
better design I think and I've added
I've added like a sparky engine category
and like forum group as well as general
programming so if you want to ask any
questions about Java C++ OpenGL whatever
anything about the Sparky engine you
have suggestions you confused about
something you can just feel free to post
there and I'll try and be more active as
well on the forums that's something that
I want to work on but anyway that's the
idea that's everything that's happened
in the past month or so it's crazy I'm
gonna try and produce videos a bit more
consistently I've settled into work now
and those of you who don't know i work
at EA by the way but i've settled into
work now after like almost three months
and I feel like I'm in a good pattern
right now to keep producing videos
outside of that and I'm not I'm kind of
kind of gotten used to my new schedule
basically one might say so that's the
idea ok if you guys enjoyed this video
please hit the like button and I will
see you guys oh one more thing before I
forget this video is going out
on a Thursday night in my Australian
isn't daylight time since it is is to
work out I'm gonna be literally
streaming all weekend it's all it's
almost going to be like a lot of dare
right i'll be streaming pretty much all
weekend except for sunday which is
easter but friday which is tomorrow i'll
be streaming all day so prepare
yourselves for that if you want to watch
that because it should be a good ride
and it's almost again it's almost like
i'm doing a lot of dad that's how much
streaming i want to be doing this
weekend because this engine needs to get
done quickly so yes that is the
situation and i'll hopefully see you
guys on those streams goodbye